(chicken clucking)
(tense string music)
- It's 6:45 in the morning,
I'm feeling it.
(dramatic music)
It's Chicken Watch, baby!
It's a special day today.
I'm not on my way to pick up Chris,
I'm actually on my way
to pick up Justin Tan.
(dance music)
♪ Chicken watch, chicken
watch, chicken watch ♪
Yeah, All right, how you been?
- I'm all right.
(laughing)
- [Keith] Oh, God.
(piano glissando)
- Yeah I don't like this,
I just got transferred
from the driver's seat,
to the passenger's seat--
- Oh, do you want to switch, should we?
- And now I'm in the back seat?
- Well typically Chris drives.
- Well, typically I drive.
- Oh really?
- But now I'm just slowly
getting knocked back.
- Well do you want to sit up here?
- [Justin] Yeah.
- Do you want to make
Justin sit in the back?
So, last time we had Tokyo fried chicken,
it was incredible.
Oh wow, it's light and crispy.
- [Chris] It's like a potato chip.
- This really feels like a southern meal,
but the flavors are all crazy.
I think it's some of
the best fried chicken I've ever had.
- It gave us some peace,
some peace of mind.
- [Keith] But today,
we're going to Lao Tao,
we're doing some Taiwanese
spicy popcorn chicken,
and Justin has actually been here before!
- Oh yeah.
- You look very much
like a Sith back there.
- Oh, a Sith.
- [Together] Chicken watch!
- Chicken watch.
- [Man] Just got to go by the gym.
- All right and one, two, three.
Hey, who are you and where are we?
- I'm David, I'm the owner of Lao Tao,
and today we're introduce
the popcorn chicken.
(funky music)
Basically, it's one of the
most popular street foods in Taiwan.
Every street corner you're gonna
find popcorn chicken everywhere.
- Everywhere makes it?
- Yes.
- It's like hot dogs in New York,
it's like all over the place.
- There you go, there you go.
There you go.
- What is the history of the
Taiwanese popcorn chicken?
- According to legend--
- Love a good legend.
- Yeah, the owner of the chicken farm,
basically the business was kind of slow,
and there were a lot
of chickens left over,
so they basically chopped
up a lot of those chickens,
and started selling them
as fried popcorn chickens.
- Every part of the buffalo style.
You know?
- There you go, there you go.
- And buffalo sometimes,
is a word for chicken.
(chuckling)
- [Together] Chicken watch.
(upbeat music)
♪ Everybody look at me ♪
♪ I'm wide awake, I'm ready to eat ♪
♪ And take and take and take ♪
♪ Taking the Chicken that is made for me ♪
♪ Little popcorn kernels,
baby, can't you see ♪
♪ I'm gonna throw 'em in the air ♪
♪ And catch 'em in my
mouth, swallow the chicken ♪
♪ And it goes down south ♪
♪ Feelin' really good, spicy popcorn ♪
♪ Popcorn chicken from Taiwan ♪
- [Together] Chicken watch!
- All right, this is
learning how to cook chicken.
Could you walk us through,
how to make your popcorn
chicken sort of step-by-step?
- At the beginning, of course you have to
cut the chicken into little pieces,
then you marinate the chicken,
we have about seven to ten
different spices we put in.
Minced garlic.
- Wow.
- Minced ginger.
You wanna use shovels or the hands?
- I wanna use shovels!
- There you go.
Oh, yes, shovel that chick.
- But then we add Mijiu,
which is the Taiwanese rice wine.
That's one of the main ingredients.
And there's the star anus.
Oh, I'm sorry.
(laughing)
- Star anus, wait.
- Star, star anise.
- Anise, anise, anise.
- Star anise.
- It does taste like anus on it's own.
- We bread them,
and we kind of powder them.
I just imagine usually we do like,
ten times this amount.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- Do you have a bigger sifter?
- Right, that's a lot of prep.
- [David] Yeah.
- I grew up with two big sifters,
and they were so mean to me.
Justin, do you wanna lay down a
quick rap about what we're doing here?
- A quick rap?
- Yeah, are you ready for this?
♪ Check it, check it, check it ♪
♪ In this kitchen ♪
♪ Just making some ♪
♪ Chicken ♪
♪ Yeah, Keith and Chris ♪
♪ Giving a little kiss ♪
- Should we?
- Give him a little kiss.
- Should we do a kiss?
Okay.
- Well, that was the weirdest
thing I've ever heard.
(laughter)
- Well, we haven't done that before.
- That's straight hip-hop, baby.
- Then you fry it.
- No, actually we par fry
it, and then we deep fry it.
Once it's fried, then we season it with
popcorn chicken powder, powder, powder.
- Oh, nice hard dust!
Oh, wow, I got a little
dust up the nostrils,
but it feels good.
- One of the secret ingredients I use.
I shouldn't be telling you guys,
but we are doing a...
- Secrets....
- Another dish that uses
the shitiake mushrooms,
we use the shiitake juice
to marinate the chicken.
So you're gonna taste this
flavor in the chicken.
- David, shh!
- These are the type of secrets I want!
- [Together] Chicken watch!
- Ow, I just remembered,
last time I was here
was the last meal I had
with my ex-girlfriend.
(somber music)
♪ Found a picture of you ♪
Then we broke up, a day later.
- [David] Okay.
- This hicken doesn't
make people break up.
- I hope not.
(laughs)
- Oh we all hope not, David.
- Yeah.
- Are you okay, dude?
- Yeah, it's okay, it
just hit me right now.
- I'm sorry to hear that.
- [Justin] Sorry to bring it down.
- Did she just want
something less spicy, and you
were delivering like a
Taiwanese level of spice?
- I was delivering a Taiwanese
level of spice, for sure.
- And she wanted something more mild.
- Yeah.
- All right, well then
you don't need her anyway.
- No, exactly.
- You're just gonna trudge through it.
- Yeah, that's right.
- You can let go slowly.
- Yeah, but no, this place
brought back those memories.
(laughter)
- [Together] Chicken watch!
- So Justin, we have a rubric,
crispiness, the moisture, the salinity,
which is sort of the seasoning.
- Salinity?
- Yeah, we sort of picked this up.
- What does that word mean?
- It means salt content typically.
- Yeah, that's what I thought.
- The sucrosity, we
learned about serenity.
- Serenity?
- Yeah.
- We misheard whatever the other one is,
what's the other one, sal-saltanity?
- We never get it right.
- Satanity.
- Not satanity, salinity.
- [Together] Chickenwatch.
(metal music)
(speaking foreign language)
- All right.
Oh, I love that it's salty.
So we're gonna start
actually with the non spicy.
We got to make an extra
batch of that anyway,
just so we can taste the
flavors a little more.
So, everybody stab a chick.
- [Chris] Oh, my god.
- Probably not the best way to say it.
(chuckles)
(speaking foreign language)
- All right.
(upbeat music)
- It's awesome.
- Hmm.
- Like the chew of it
is like very delightful,
very crunchy, very salty.
- It's a little french fry-ish to me.
- Mm-hmm, I'm gettin' that
umami mushroom taste at the end.
- [Chris] Yeah.
- It's like on my tongue
like I ate mushrooms.
- Mm-hmm.
Takes me back to the mother land.
- Have you been?
- No.
- I'm of European decent but
I've never been to Europe.
No one will invite me there.
- Is this about me?
- I was open about it.
- I don't know do you
want to make it about you?
(suspenseful music)
- This chicken doesn't
make people break up?
- I hope not.
(suspenseful music)
- You know, why don't we try the mild?
This is what they said is
the only level we should try.
(laughs)
This will be spicy enough.
- I just touch a little bit
with my tongue and I went like,
woo.
- That's plenty of heat.
- That's all you need.
It's a little bit of a
hot Cheetos's feeling.
- Uh huh, yeah.
- Where you're just like--
- Oh I got to eat more.
- Gotta have more.
- Cause if I stop, I'll die.
- The salt level is really nice.
- Yeah.
- It's really good salinity.
- Woo, my mouth's getting hot.
Oh, boy.
- This has gotten much less spicy to me
just eating a couple bites.
- Really?
I'm opposite for me.
I'm sweatin'.
- Look we can go to Europe,
we can all go to Europe.
(suspenseful music)
- Look at the shape of this guy,
look at him, look a him.
- I mean he warned us
that level two is going
to be pretty hot.
- Yeah he said this
would be more than enough
and we shouldn't eat this.
(speaking foreign language)
- Oh, yep okay.
- Oh, whoa there it is.
There it is, I was like,
"It tastes just like the previous one."
And then now, and now--
- It lasts longer.
- It hits the top and
the sides of the tongue.
(coughs)
(cheers)
How spicy is this spicy chicken?
- Oh there's a bunch of spices, at least,
like seven to ten different
spices go into it.
- Maybe Howlin' Ray's changed my pallet
but that's not crazy spicy.
Do you think you can
handle the third level?
- I kind of didn't want
to try it and I was going
to let you guys just try it.
Now that this wasn't that
bad, I'm gonna go for it.
- So you're saying you were gonna back out
at the last minute?
- I already told you.
- Of commitment.
- Oh, I was open about it.
- Is this about me?
- You didn't want to be up
by 7:15 and then it was 7:30,
then 7:38 when you came outside.
- Well you tried to put
me in the back seat,
when I was supposed to
be the driver of the car
and then all of a sudden
I'm in the back seat.
- When there's a new
car in the relationship,
you use the new car.
This chicken doesn't make
people break up, break up,
break up?
- Wow, wow.
- Really?
- Wow.
(evil laugh)
- Yeah, let's just ignore the problem.
- [Together] Chicken watch!
♪ When you see the fried
chicken sittin' on the counter ♪
♪ Counter, counter, counter, counter ♪
♪ When you see that fried chicken ♪
♪ When you, when you
see that fried chicken ♪
♪ When you see that fried chicken ♪
♪ This is how we eat it ♪
♪ Really, really greedy and
chicken with the needy ♪
♪ Yeah, I'm really, really greedy
and chicken with the needy ♪
♪ This is how we eat it ♪
♪ I'm greedy ♪
- Supposedly, we only have,
uh, four levels, non-spicy,
mild, medium, extra spice.
But we also have a Taiwanese Spicy.
- So some of these chicken
pieces are significantly redder
than others.
- I picked kind of a red one.
- I think we'd be
willing to go all the way
to the Taiwanese level of spice.
- You don't want to go there.
- We don't want to go there?
- I don't want to go there.
- Not even like one bite?
- No.
(speaking foreign language)
- Okay, I'm ready for it.
- Oh boy, that one does taste different.
- You got to trust the chef man.
When the chef tells you not
to do it and you're like,
I want, no, you're wrong.
- Wow, yeah it tastes like pepper.
- Mm-hmm.
- That's crazy.
- I didn't say he was wrong.
(groans)
- Oh, I have Asian customers come in,
I warn them of the extra
spicy and then they do it
and they came back like, "You're right."
Should just go medium.
(groans)
- It is a different type
of spice than yesterday.
- It is good.
- I'm on top of it right now.
- My brows getting hot.
It hurts a lot but
there's something to it.
- Keith, it's like you got a
little hit of that spicy thing
and you want it again.
- There's something there.
- Keith!
- I know it hurts me a
lot but I don't know.
- I can eat fire, I can do anything.
You want to take another ride.
- I just don't, I just
don't want to live in fear.
- I like that.
- It's kind of like a relationship.
- [Together] Chicken watch!
- Hi there, hey we've got some friends.
Hey, you want to come
eat some chicken with us?
Come here, it's really spicy.
- You can handle it?
- Yeah.
- All right.
(suspenseful music)
- What are you talking
about it wasn't that spicy?
- [Together] Chicken watch!
- Chicken, watch.
- Wow, Chris you're really good at that.
- Thanks, you want to toss one to me?
- Yeah, okay.
Hey man, I'm sorry about
everything that happened earlier.
You use one hand to hold
it and one hand to pour it.
- I heard him.
- Okay, I'm just, okay.
- I'm sorry too, it was
kind of this weird energy.
- [Keith] I feel like
I was pushing you away.
- No but I was also late, so.
- Let's put the stake of our relationship
in you catching this chicken.
(dramatic music)
- Holy.
(cheering)
- We're not like Justin
and his girlfriend.
- We'll stay together,
only Justin is lonely.
Yes, yes.
Chicken watch.
- Chicken watch.
(upbeat music)
- [Together] Chicken watch.
- Congratulations, bud.
- You're free.
- You're free, man.
- You made it.
It's just a drawing,
that drawing has no power
over you anymore.
- No, definitely not.
- Chicken's about rebirth, renewal.
- That's why they always
say, which came first,
the chicken or the egg?
- Maybe they came together,
does that make sense?
- Yeah.
- Sometimes you got to crack
and egg to make an omelet.
Don't count your chickens
before they hatch.
- Because you just don't know
if there might be two chickens
in one of the eggs.
(laughs)
- [Chris] Why did the
chicken cross the road?
- [Keith] To get to the other side.
- Of what?
The relationship.
(victorious music)
- Chicken watch.
- Two case, 18.
(laughing)
- [Together] Chicken watch!
- We normally say it a lot.
One last question, David.
- Sure.
- Uh, do you think that
Taiwanese Spicy popcorn chicken
is the best fried chicken in the world?
- I won't say that 'cause
we're always improving
on the dishes.
We tweak a little bit
every other two weeks,
you keep on improving.
That's how you do it.
- This is definitely the
most snackable fried chicken,
that I've had in a long time.
- And it's really good fried chicken.
- Oh, it's great fried
chicken and normally,
I don't want to be a bummer
but normally I'm only about
the bone in, you know?
I don't, I don't even
fuck around with stuff
that doesn't have bones in it.
And this, I could fuck with
this, you know what I'm saying?
- Mh-hmm.
- It's fuckable.
♪ Popcorn chicken from Taiwan ♪
- So we're on our way
on our way to Hot Star.
It is a Taiwanese chicken fast food joint.
- How do you guys not just shit
your brains out on the show?
- Oh no, that's part of it.
Well now I'm on my way
to snack on some chicks,
a big, big filet.
It's bigger than my dick
and it's also not the shape
of my dick and it's also
not the taste of my dick
and it's also not the shape of my dick
and it's also not the taste of my dick.
- [Together] Chicken watch 2K18.